So "mom guilt" is unfortunately kind of universal.
A lot of women blame themselves first and
foremost when life doesn’t feel in balance
or in check, in terms of managing career and
family and home.
And it’s really, really – it’s not reasonable
to expect that anybody would have that balance,
given the lack of respect that our country
shows for new parenthood.
Now, that said, I don’t mean to blame the
victim, but it’s something that we can kind
of control.
So when I did the research for my book I interviewed
and surveyed more than 800 new parents.
And what I found when I looked at the transcripts
of the longer, deeper interviews is that the
word “guilt” popped up again and again
and again.
Only what I was actually sort of surprised
to see is that it meant really different things
to different mothers.
So there were some mothers who felt really
guilty leaving their baby to go back to work
and leaving the baby in someone’s care who
they felt like maybe was not quite as capable
as they would be themselves of loving the
baby.
There were other people who actually felt
guilty because they loved being back at work.
And I experienced both of those feelings.
When I went back to work after having my first
son and my second, my husband was in his medical
residency.
There was no real choice for me to make about
the income that our family needed.
And so I didn’t feel terribly conflicted
about going back to work.
It just felt like it was too soon and it was
not in the most supportive cultural circumstances
that I would have wanted.
So what I say to women is, first of all, guilt
implies that you’ve made some sort of wrong
decision.
That there’s some other “better, less
guilty” working mom out there who you should
aspire to be like.
But erase that idea, because every single
mother out there will admit to feeling guilt
in one way or another, right?
So if it is just a lowest common denominator,
let’s just erase it and treat for whatever
feeling we actually have.
If you feel regretful, if you feel conflicted,
if you feel overwhelmed, if you feel unsupported,
let’s solve that problem rather than writing
something off universally as “mom guilt”.
You don’t really hear people talk about
“dad guilt,” and I would actually really
welcome that conversation, and I think dads
would actually quite like to be a part of
that conversation.
But it feels kind of antifeminist actually
to just call all of this conflict that we
have about this transition back to work after
baby—to call it “mom guilt”.
And it’s something that’s perpetuated
if you don’t acknowledge sort of the reasons
for why you’re having these feelings early
on, they snowball and they can make it harder
and harder for women to stay in the workplace.
We know that 30 percent of professional women
drop out of the workplace within a year of
having a baby.
Even in the most progressive couples, even
in couples that came into their couplehood
saying, “We’re going to be equal partners,”
if mom is learning everything in that time
about how to care for the baby—and mom also
probably is part of this generation that I’m
part of too where we want to achieve everything
as women—We feel we deserve it and we do
to be great at everything and to find answers
and solutions.
And so we’ve become sort of professional
perfectionists at parenting.
But dad’s off at work and we’re learning
how to do that.
And then when mom goes back to work and both
parents – and I’m being binary about it
but it is obviously for partners as well,
same sex partners, when you come home at the
end of the day guess who knows how to do everything?
Mom.
And guess who wants everything done her way?
And there’s a term for that, and it’s
called “gatekeeping.”
And there are a number of studies that show
that if dad has time alone with the baby or
the partner has time alone with the baby after
mom goes back to work and is able to take
intermittent leave—you know, so just say
even a month at home taking care of the baby
and learning some of these things on the ground—that
it actually sets up a much better balance
that continues through forever, essentially.
There’s a study that shows that fathers
who take parental leave ultimately have better
relationships with their teenage children,
which is amazing.
And you think about who’s a teenager now,
who that study was done on, and these are
pretty progressive dads back then.
And yet I’m really glad we can learn from
them.
We don’t stop necessarily to look back and
assess and see that sometimes being a little
more long lensed about it, realizing that,
you know, offering a parent an additional
two months of paid leave will make all the
difference in the world.
We also, of course, have a huge gender parity
problem.
There’s an amazingly convincing study that
shows that for every month of parental leave
that a father takes, the mom’s lifetime
earnings increase by seven percent, which
is incredible.
And yet when we look at who is actually taking
leave, of course, I mean I don’t even need
to tell you this: Mothers take longer leave
than fathers—globally, but more so in the
United States than anywhere else.